it is as foul smelling as it is
unsightly sea life dead and washed
ashore essentially choked by an algae
bloom known as red tide they appear to
be cleaned up at this beach in Naples on
Florida's Gulf Coast but on a bad day
red tide can have an impact on tourism
as businesses here are still recovering
from Hurricane Ian last year the ocean
breeze carries the toxin released by The
Red Tide algae ashore where it can cause
health problems for people from scratchy
throats to irritated eyes all the way
into difficulty breathing and asthma
attacks while it is a naturally
occurring algae this team from the water
school at Florida Gulf Coast University
is looking into whether pollution is
making the blooms worse so pollution may
be aggravating the problem it may be
aggravating the problem it definitely is
not the cause of the problem but it may
be aggravating the problem